- [Interviewer] All right. Bonafide.
Bonafide, where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- So, really I feel like
I grew up a lot of places,
but I was born in Long
Beach and Lucerne Valley.
I was raised a little bit,
a part of my early childhood
in wonderful Jackson, Alabama
with my dad's side of the family.
And I came back to California
when I was 15.
I got pregnant.
They didn't want our last name to be,
you know, messed up.
So I got pregnant too early.
So I came back to California.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about your family.
You had both your parents?
- I never had both of my parents.
Always has them separately.
But my mom, she was in and out of jail.
And my dad, he was out there in Alabama.
- [Interviewer] Who raised you?
- My grandmother and my dad.
Yeah.
But my dad stopped raising me when
I was able tell on him.
You know, for molesting me.
And raping and molesting
me from the age of 9 to 15.
And I was finally able to tell somebody.
I ended up getting pregnant.
- [Interviewer] With your dad?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- Sure. I have a child by my father.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And he's fine?
Or he or she is fine?
- Yeah. She's fine.
She has her ups and downs, you know,
but she's doesn't have any deformities.
However, she has cerebral palsy.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I see.
- Mhmm.
- [Interviewer] Okay. So you
came to LA at what age again?
- I came to LA, back
to Los Angeles, at 15.
Uh-huh.
I had got too fast out there in Alabama.
I started, I started hoeing.
- [Interviewer] Even then?
- Uh huh.
- [Interviewer] Back in Alabama?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Oh, is that right?
- I started hoeing.
It's like I growed more to sex
than away from sex, you know?
So it was...
- [Interviewer] So you
started at what age?
- I started 13.
- [Interviewer] 13? Wow.
- Yeah.
And so, you know...
a lot of people that get molested,
they run away from sex.
So they went away from men or whatnot.
You know, that wasn't me.
I ran to it.
I'm not really addicted to it,
but addicted to the attention from it.
So yeah.
Now I'm out here in Los Angeles.
I still hoe.
- [Interviewer] You're
working in Figueroa?
- Ah, I work all over.
I work...
I didn't-
I done been there on Sepulveda Boulevards.
I've actually worked all over.
I worked in Memphis,
Tennessee on 9th street.
I mean, I worked in Oakland
on Mac Arthur and Market.
You know, San Pablo, Gary
and Lorcan and San Diego.
I mean, I just been all the way around
from the West coast to the East coast.
- [Interviewer] You started 13.
Is this all you've ever done for money?
- Oh yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah?
I've never had a job.
- [Interviewer] How old are you now?
- I'm 38.
- [Interviewer] 38.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And you have one child?
- I have seven kids.
- [Interviewer] Seven kids?
- Yes. I have six girls and one boy.
- [Interviewer] And are
you raising them all?
- No, I don't raise any of them.
My kids went to foster homes
due to my drug addiction.
And...
Yeah. A part of me
being a prostitute,
I had never smoked.
I had never drinked.
I didn't even like cigarettes, you know?
At the age of 22,
when I got out of
California Youth Authority,
I went to California Youth
Authority for attempted murder.
When I got out of there, you know,
I had made this plan when I
was in there to, you know,
just become the best
prostitute ever, you know?
And I had like this business
format and everything.
However, when I got out, I met this dude.
I fell in love with this dude.
So it was awesome.
At first.
At least I thought I was
just magically in love.
And you know, he left
and he went on vacation.
Well, his dad had just got out of jail.
His dad was staying with us or whatnot.
And I got depressed because
I was looking at looking at
some old stuff and I realized that he had
a whole nother life.
And that's why he was on vacation.
Well, anyways, it sent
me to a depression period
and I started smoking
crack with his father
to come up out of the depression.
Like the first time I did
it, it was like, Oh my God.
I'm not calling his phone
every time I think about him.
Or back to back.
It was amazing, you know?
And then it's like the prostituting
or whatever became a
whole different field.
I mean, it wasn't the
pimping and the hoeing.
Now I had-
Hell, I had a pimp as a pipe, you know.
And everything that I did
was to get that, you know.
It took me a while to slow down, you know,
because I had got on heroin.
I had got on crystal meth.
I just did so much shit.
It seemed like every time
that I started doing good
or I went to a program or
something, I had this...
dream of becoming a
truck driver or whatever,
it seemed like something will always
lead me right back to hoeing.
Even if it wasn't prostitutin'.
Even if it wasn't smoking drugs.
It's like I would start
hoeing for a little bit.
And then, you know, right back in there.
- [Interviewer] What do you
think the attraction is?
- I think the attraction is
the attention that I get.
It's amazing for somebody
to ride down the street and honk at me.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. I mean at night.
At midnight down there.
You see the traffic jams
on the side streets-
- Right, right.
- [Interviewer] Just to
interact with the girls.
- I mean, it's amazing for me,
for a guy to even pull up and be like,
Oh my God, you got such a beautiful smile.
Or you got such beautiful eyes.
Or gosh are those yours?
(laughs)
Just that attention. It'd be like, man.
- [Interviewer] So maybe it's
a little self-esteem boost.
- Yes, it is.
That I can guarantee.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. Because
there's so many girls out.
- Yes, there is.
- [Interviewer] And there's so many guys
sitting there in cars ignoring them.
- Right. They don't have to stop at me.
- [Interviewer] It sounds
like the girls come out there
just to get the self-esteem
boost, it seems.
- Yeah, maybe.
- [Interviewer] And some money.
- Well, yeah.
I mean, that helps.
I mean, especially if you need
a room or you need clothes
or you need food or whatnot.
And I do spend my money
on those things, you know.
I have a mobile home.
- [Interviewer] Is that where you live?
- Yeah. I stay in a mobile home.
- [Interviewer] Oh, really?
- I bought me a mobile home
last year and it's great.
It's great.
You know, I don't date in my mobile home
or anything like that.
I go get a room, but still.
'Cause you know, I come
from a family that you,
where you just don't shit where you lay.
So I don't date out of my mobile home.
But hey, they pick me up there.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. And they
go to a hotel or whatever.
- Yeah.
Sometimes. It mostly is car dates.
- [Interviewer] Oh, is that right?
- Mostly it's car dates
because a lot of them,
a lot of the dates come between, you know,
like three in the morning
to six in the morning.
It's they work time, you know?
So a lot of them, just let
me get in, let me get out.
- [Interviewer] On the way to work.
- Yeah. So I call that
early morning traffic hours.
So yeah, that was my best hours.
My best days are Sunday.
I love Sundays.
I just love, you know,
because Sunday you get
real lot of attention.
You know, even the women stop and be like,
"Girl, you want to go to church?"
(laughs)
So you don't.
So Sundays is really my best day.
Not that I make a lot
of money on that day.
Oh yeah. I do.
I think I make more money on Sundays
than I do any other day.
- [Interviewer] How much money
will you make a good day?
- Well, I'm not young anymore.
(laughs)
- [Interviewer] You're still beautiful.
- So because of the age bracket,
you know what I'm saying?
I used to bring in like 1200 a night
when I was, you know, 17.
To where I was, you know, 38.
Now I bring, well, I still
keep myself with a quarter.
And that quarter is $500. I don't care.
Well, you know, because-
and that's not including my smoking habit.
- [Interviewer] Have you
been arrested before?
- Oh yeah, I got whole cases. Good lord.
And like I told you, I went to the
California Youth Authority
for attempted murder.
So I did some time there.
But it's only been,
you know, prostitution.
You know, a lot of
misdemeanors and two felonies.
Yeah. One, I had a robbery with it.
One of the Johns out there and
I really didn't do it,
but I had to take the case
because my grandmother was dying.
And that lady is the one that rescued me
from Jackson, Alabama, and
brought me back to California.
And she was like an angel to me.
And so they gave her a
certain time to live.
So I went to court.
Never in a million years did I imagine
that they was going to come
up at me with this deal of,
you know, you can get
out today, time served.
You know, I had been in there
nine months fighting this case
and time served.
A strike and five years probation.
Run it, you know what I'm sayin'?
And I've been in there nine months
already fighting this case.
And I just tired of
stripping and showing my ass,
you know, to the deputies.
They wasn't giving me any money for it.
You know?
And hey.
I think that's why I don't
have hoe cases no more
because it's such a thing
as car regulars, you know?
And that's why I'm
always good to the Johns.
I don't care who they are,
what walk of life they came from.
I don't care if they rich. None of that.
I was thinking, as long as
I get them a bomb ass time,
they gonna want to come back to me.
- [Interviewer] Have
you had bad experiences?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Have
you had bad experiences?
- Oh hell yeah.
I mean...
I remember this one guy
told me because of my smile
he wasn't going to shoot
me in the head with his 9
because I wouldn't suck
his dick without a condom.
I told him to shoot me.
I'm out here anyways.
I'm already suicidal.
Just do me the favor, you know?
And that's really the
way I felt, you know?
And that's the way I still feel.
If I just so happen to get into a bad car,
because you know, it's a lot
of people are just trying
to rob people and (indistinct).
But what I tell them is, you
know, you can take my purse.
You know, you're just be practicing.
Because that's what it is.
I'm not fixin' to carry
no money in my purse.
None of that, you know.
I just stuck my whole, my
money in a hole in the ground.
Just to keep it, you know?
And I will never forget that guy.
You know, I had it.
You know, I got cut by the knife man.
I don't know if a lot of
people remember the knife man,
but the knife man was the one
that was cutting the girls up
and putting them in trash cans.
The police calls him the knife man.
Well, I was the one of the
ones that the knife man let go.
And I'm greatly appreciated for that.
Although it was only five
of us that was let go.
I'm grateful.
- [Interviewer] Had you been raped before?
And I'm sure, and stuff like that.
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] You've been raped before?
- Hell yeah.
I was raped by my daddy. I was raped.
I was molested by my biological father.
I have a baby by him.
I was raped by several different men.
But I feel like when I
go through those crises,
sometimes, I mean, like before
I used to cry, you know.
Because I was with a
pimp then and you know,
it just had to be done.
You know, I didn't want
to get my ass whipped.
I didn't want to do a lot of
things that I did, you know?
Somebody took the virginity of my ass,
which is the only thing I
thought was a virgin on me.
You know? And...
I just feel like I have
nothing else left to do
but get this shit right.
For real, you know?
I remember my granny used to tell me
just to be the best at everything you do.
You know, at one point in
time I became homeless.
I was staying in a tent.
I used to stay on Skid Row.
- [Interviewer] Oh, really?
- Downtown.
Yeah. Used to stay on Skid Row.
I just started putting my money up
and I said, "Fuck a pimp."
You know, I started
saying, "Fuck the pipe."
And I had to cortel my habit. Period.
I went to school before, you know.
Like I told you,
I wanted to own my own
trucking company one day.
But I have to stop whoring first.
- [Interviewer] Can you tell
me about your experiences
working with a pimp?
- Those are some bad experiences.
Outside of being beat.
Oh, I been beat with a broken water hose.
Wet.
I done been through a lot of stuff, man.
Especially with a pimp.
Up underneath my breasts, I have a scar
from a pimp trying to take out my heart.
And he said that I was too kind to people
and he needs to cut it out.
And you know...
I've had some pain with pimps.
I don't see how men can do
women the way they do them.
The way that they did me, you know.
One of my pimps had
several other men come in.
And it was 21 men to come
in one behind another.
I just laid there numb.
I just was numb.
And I don't think I'll ever forget that.
And that makes me not want to...
several different times,
made me not want to hoe anymore.
Not wanting to smoke
drugs anymore or not...
I mean, if you could sit in the courtroom
and have your parental rights terminated
because you don't want to
stop hoeing and get on track.
I just can't bring myself to
cure that addiction just yet.
Do I think that I will one day? Yeah.
I think I gained enough money
to get my trucking company.
But right now, I just haven't.
- [Interviewer] So you still have hope.
- Oh, hell yeah.
- [Interviewer] You're strong.
- Hell yeah.
You know, I think that I'm
going to get a great big house
and put all hoes in, you know?
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
- I really do, you know.
I date this man.
He said that he was gonna marry
me, but I don't think he is.
You know, he knows that
I have an addiction
and he don't take my money or anything.
He treat me as though we're
in a relationship and...
Yeah.
He's a vet and he has a lot of knowledge
and a lot of wisdom.
And I think that-
And we've been trying to get a house.
And not just a little room
house because I do plan to
take hoes off the streets
in the near future.
And when I say the near future,
I mean like the next two months.
I'm going to get everybody that I can.
And that's where I'm gonna start at.
You know, I am going to charge them rent.
That's it.
I don't want they money for a horn.
I don't want none of that.
I just, I want them to get better.
And I feel like if they know my testimony
and they know my struggles,
it's going to happen.
- [Interviewer] And by
doing it for others,
you're doing it for yourself.
- Yeah.
I know that my testimony
is gonna save a lot of prostitutes.
So that they don't have to go.
I'm not getting graphic in it.
And really I can.
Probably not drunk enough.
But I have some stories.
And I know that my testimony
will one day save plenty.
- [Interviewer] What's the worst thing?
I mean, that gun story was horrible.
- The worst thing I had happen to me
was I had somebody take my virginity
of my ass.
And that was brutal to me.
He put in a thing around my neck.
He wrapped it like this.
Had me in doggy style.
And he was burning me with
cigarettes on my back.
I have the bruises, the
scars. I have all of that.
And you know, I had to get
27 stitches in my anal.
He was pushing big dildos and a stick,
you know, to open it up more.
- [Interviewer] It's all right.
What would you say to a young girl?
Considering...
- I would tell them to...
I would tell them to...
Excuse me, sorry.
I'd tell them...
to...
keep hope alive.
And...
there is a chance that one day,
if with the right mind
and with the right tools
and with the right guidance,
that you can become what you want.
And I'm sure it wasn't a prostitute.
There is a big, huge chance
that if you make the willingness
to follow through
with your goals, it'll happen.
If I had anything to say to a prostitute.
Regardless if she was young or old.
I'll tell them you still
got a chance, baby.
And that's what I would tell them.
And Lord's willing, a
lot of hoes will see me.
A lot of pimps will get to know me,
because I ain't gonna stop.
I'm not going to stop.
And I feel like I can save
people and I'm going to.
- [Interviewer] That
was beautiful, Bonafide.
Thank you very much.
- You're very welcome.
Thank you for letting me share.
Thank you.
- [Interviewer] You're
such a good speaker.
- That's dedication. You were right.
- [Interviewer] It's therapeutic, right?
Because I feel so good.
I feel like my day is just the business.
Already and I haven't even been
through the day. Thank you.
Appreciate it.
- [Interviewer] No, I appreciate you.
(quiet speaking)